the topic of abstinence only sex
education is resurfacing as a
conservative Republican priority in the
Trump era which is just hilarious
because of the number of sex scandals
related to Trump which directly
contradict the concept of just
abstaining from sex and also opposition
to birth control and historically the
right has had this totally illogical
position on this issue which is that
they don't want abortions but they want
to teach abstinence only sex education
instead of comprehensive sex ed with
access to affordable contraceptives and
the reason that it's incoherent is that
we know that abstinence only sex ed
doesn't work right it leads to more
pregnancy and when you have more people
getting pregnant without wanting to be
pregnant
that increases the demand for abortion
so that's the general idea but now we're
hearing from the conservatives in the
Department of Health and Human Services
that they are now under trump shifting
back to pushing abstinence only sex
education and they're just super excited
and the way that it's working is that
under Title 10 title 10 has been around
since Nixon it's a federal grant that
gives money to programs for family
planning and preventive health services
and the idea that the Trump DHHS is
using is when they get title 10 requests
they are encouraging the recipients to
push abstinence only sex education if
they want the money and the funny and
really sad part is that as this is
happening we're getting more and more
data from when President Obama was
president and under Obama we had a focus
not on abstinence but we had a focus on
comprehensive sex ed access to birth
control we saw a decline in teen
pregnancy in other words as we are
learning the obvious reality that the
Obama approach reduced teen pregnancy we
are seeing the trump dhhs go back to
let's push abstinence only education
which we know doesn't work and not only
doesn't it work but the hypocrisy of the
Trump administration promoting this is
just laughable did Trump use
contraception with stormy Daniels to
prevent pregnancy if so how can the
administration credibly teach something
different and the answer is the results
don't matter the results have never
mattered I've spoken to you about this
term strict father morality for a very
long time even if you make the logical
case to a conservative that hey your
goal is reduce abortion to do that we've
got to reduce unwanted pregnancy the way
to reduce unwanted pregnancy is access
to birth control and comprehensive sex
education and you would think it would
be an obvious yes to the conservative
but the strict father moralist of the
Religious Right says now because what
you're doing is you are giving license
for a recreational non-procreative sex
outside of marriage and really the
priority is to prevent that not to
actually reduce the number of
pregnancies which reduces the number of
abortions and once you understand that a
lot of right-wing policy actually makes
a lot more sense the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad